thank you
let's kick into it and then I can give
you back your Friday afternoons uh
welcome everyone uh to this
extraordinary council meeting uh do we
have any apologies
looks like we're all here I'm going to
go ahead and assume there's no conflicts
of interest for the one item today
uh we will go ahead
um and welcome up Andy Fraser
um to the stand and we'll get you sworn
in
so if you read that declaration I mean
I Andrew Campbell Fraser declare I will
faithfully and impartially and according
to the best of my skills and judgment
execute and perform in the best entrance
of the gore District the powers
authorities duties vested in or opposed
upon me as a counselor of the gore
District Council by virtual Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official information and meeting act
1987 or any other Act
full
congratulations thank you very much
let's take a seat over the table if you
want
and with that if there is would anyone
would you like to any words uh there
andy or you've got the chance
I don't want to say too much but just
anybody that's watching thanks very much
um it's something I've actually wanted
to get my teeth into for quite a long
time and a great group of people here
with the best interests and Gore at
heart so thank you
thank you for that and congratulations
again it's it's nice to feel whole again
uh did any councils want to make any
comment
I'm going forward
well done uh and that's it for today
just as easy as that thank you very much
for attending um and I will declare them
any clothes well done